Hello Freak bitches,
but that's what v D is vds of a sexual
transmitted disease.
When you think about some of the having
Vd,
and when I was about 17 my friend fucked
his sister's best friend and he got
something.
He got VD,
he got vd and we went there the next day
and there was a chick with like fucking
like the Phantom of the opera mark on a
face.
Oh Dog.
It was fucking crazy.
What was the mark on her face like she,
she had like syphilis,
a son home.
Got It.
She got a cut in the lip and she sucked
the fuck the thickness and it ran.
I know,
forget this.
It's not even funny.
It was really sad because I didn't know
what she had.
I just went there with my friend.
My friend goes,
you got to go in there with me.
They'll come scan at the walk in there.
Wow,
nice.
Let's go.
What's the big deal?
They're going to give you pills,
whatever.
I didn't know.
I wasn't sexually active at that age
like hey was,
and we went in there while I was waiting
for him dog.
This chick cameron did paperwork and she
turned around and she had gotten
something that started here.
Like she,
you know,
she had like a cod or what's that?
When you have chapped lips or something
and all of this was like half purple and
red.
She sucks something bad.
And after that I was like,
Ooh,
I gotta be careful out there.
It's a jungle.
That was the thing when we were kids,
like someone has vd,
ah,
she's got VD,
be careful.
He's got vd,
you know,
someone haven't,
vd was like,
Whoa,
you hear d here?
Betty got beady.
Oh that fucking Carl got feet d
facebook friends with me from high
school.
A pussy wouldn't get wet.
So they used to call the dry Hump
Jersey.
They used to call her fairview,
New Jersey.
Oh,
oh,
oh.
Oh.
People are so fucked up.
Girl was banging.
This girl was fucking banging though.
So you'd have to like bring vaseline or
something.
Yeah,
she was from Wayne,
New Jersey and she was banging.
She moved to North Program.
I guess she was a sophomore and she was
dating a few guys and shouldn't things
happen?
Like I was friends with.
I know she didn't like me.
Like she,
she just didn't like me for some reason.
I didn't think the world are either.
And one nine 84 I'm at a bar and this
bitch comes in.
I mean banging,
banging,
banging though.
Also said she had some type of Vd,
so they called the lorry jacked,
you know she's got the Jack now when
they see dc sang us.
Oh,
he's got the Jack Jack.
Jack said he used to call her name and
Jack like that was like,
they did just tormented this girl that
she date,
like a rocky,
like a rock guy.
Len had like long hair and one night I
saw rocky and she was banging Joe Rogan,
right?
Yeah.
Bagging.
And I go,
you live in North Bergen?
I,
she's like,
yeah,
I didn't go to college.
I,
I'm a,
I'm a nanny.
She told me the guy's name and I knew
that guy.
That guy had a massage parlor years
earlier.
The guy that she was being a nanny for,
and I didn't go.
I go,
if she's his nanny,
he's just fucking,
or something's gotta be wrong.
She looks so good.
And that mini skirt,
she disappeared like one 30
and finally like three I'm sitting and
I'm like,
what am I going to do tonight?
And I'm going to have like a bag of coke
and go fuck it.
I'm going to go get him.
So I went to,
this is how crazy hours I went to the
dude's house where she's told me I
knocked on her door was three 15 in the
morning and he's like,
oh cool,
what are you doing?
I go,
I got to talk to Lori.
There's something missing.
He goes,
hold on Laurie.
And she came down and she comes outside
and he's got a robe on.
She's got a robot and I look her
straight in the face.
I go,
listen,
I got like two eight balls in my pocket,
get dresses,
get the fuck out of here.
And she's like,
I can't.
Then I go,
you have to.
And we argued that for like 10 minutes.
I'm like,
I want to suck your pussy.
I want to do 30 things to you.
I don't give a fuck about the vfd are
the jack or the dry hump.
I'm on fire and she's like,
well,
give me 10 minutes and I don't,
how am I going to sneak out of there?
I Dunno,
so I waited outside for it.
She's like,
I put Lou on bed and I'd run out.
About 15 minutes later,
I see her running out with a person with
like a bank deposit bag.
He's like,
fuck him.
I can't take care of anymore.
Fuck him.
We were on foot.
It's four 30 in the morning.
I'm on tonally avenue.
North Bergen is a bunch of those dirty
hotels,
so I'm like,
oh,
I got a score here.
I got coke,
she's got money.
I'm going to fuck her.
I'm excited.
We go back to a hotel.
We finally registered like $30 they
asked us three we want at the Jacuzzi in
the room and shit.
It was one of those dirty hotels on
totally as you going to New York City.
We went in there,
we walk in and she goes,
rule number one,
you're not going to find me.
It's five in the morning.
That goes my fucking,
that goes this night and all of a sudden
she looks at me,
she goes,
well,
if you could guess the color of my
panties out,
fuck you.
And I'm like,
okay,
red.
And she goes,
they're green,
but good love.
We started snorting coke,
eating mass.
I mean,
it was filthy.
I woke up at five in the afternoon and
Doug Flutie was drawing that
quarterback,
that touchdown there naked,
any four 83 ducks.
I was waking up,
she was naked,
rip apart.
I'm waking up and Doug flew these drawn
the touchdown.
I got dressed and got the fuck out that
never saw her again.
Never said and robbed the money.
I took everything.
She pops up on facebook about two years
ago and I'm like,
Laurie.
She's like,
fuck you,
you fat faggot and all this shit.
She's like,
well,
you left me there that night,
but we had a good time.
Fuck yeah,
we had a good thing and I will hit her
back and go,
what color are your panties?
That's supposed to me.
Areas.
I knew.
She gave me some,
she had something,
but I didn't give a fuck.
It was 84 rock Hudson was dying.
I didn't use a condom.
I knew the consequences.
I'm like,
fuck it.
So I knew I was to get something and I
probably did.
I got crabs after that.
Over the holidays.
Say before I got crabs.
Yeah,
84 85 season.
I got crabs.
I found that in the bathroom and port
authority.
I went to port authority to take a shit
and I pulled my pants down and I'm
sitting there reading the paper and I
see a crab.
Like I saw something jump and I'm like
walked off.
Fuck.
And I had never heard it.
I never heard nothing.
I went home and told my underwear off
going like a magnifying glass.
It was over.
It was all over them.
They're all over the couch.
I had to bring a bomb and through the
room,
like one of those while I'm simply for
12 hours,
it's really,
oh,
I grabbed
it was cramped up.
Oh my God.
I be next door and knocked on my,
I was living in tenafly,
New Jersey.
Lady next door and knocked so you have a
bug problem.
I'm like,
no,
no.
Since you moved in here,
there's been crabs and shrimp.
Oh,
no.
okay.